our co-author of Thurgood Marshall
Warrior at the bar rebel on the bench
what led you to a book well justice
Marshalls life and career it's uh he's
been someone I've admired all my life
certainly from the time that I worked
with him in high school as a page in the
Supreme Court and this has been my great
ambition Michael D Davis how about you
I've been a journalist for 25 years
covering the civil rights movement
Thurgood Marshall and my father John P
Davis were very close friends I grew up
in a fact of his family that was very
involved in civil rights interestingly
enough we had the idea of writing
Thurgood Marshall's biography about a
month before he officially announced his
retirement and I thought that's many
many years of covering the civil rights
movement and writing hundreds and
hundreds of newspaper articles it was
time for me to sit down maybe in putting
it all in the book did you say John P
Davis yes and who is he that was my
father
is attorney and a very close friend and
colleague of thirded Marshalls and where
were they attorneys together my father
was a graduate of Harvard Law School and
was in Washington DC during the 30s in
the 40s 50s time when the n-double-a-cp
and Thurgood Marshall had joined the
n-double-a-cp and had started their
activism during those days reason I
asked and I'll go to your colleague here
of about John P Davis cuz John W Davis
is the white man here and this
photograph Thurgood Marshall who was he
well John W Davis was Thurgood
Marshall's adversary in the famous case
of Brown versus Board of Education John
W Davis was one of the most
distinguished advocates of his day he
was the Democratic nominee for president
in 1924 against Calvin Coolidge he later
was US ambassador to Great Britain for a
few few men have had as distinguished
career in law and politics as John W
Davis he was also the founder of the
Wall Street firm of Davis Polk and Ward
well which is still one of the most
at firms in America and earlier in his
career he was a United States Solicitor
General representing the United States
and cases that came before the Supreme
Court and it was during that time that
Thurgood Marshall actually became a
great admirer of John W Davis when
Thurgood was in law school at Howard
University he used to cut classes during
the afternoon to watch the great John W
Davis at work before the United States
Supreme Court will come back to Brown
versus the Board of Education but before
we do that I want to just chill this
cover and ask you when you look at this
cover and this man what what are the
things that you think of O Brien I think
about the fact that our way to your
Studios today coming through
Union Station which Hunter and I could
use any restroom in the station stop and
have coffee at any restaurant that was
open I think about effectively thousands
of millions of black children who now
can go to adequate schools the very fact
that right here in Washington DC
unlike in Thurgood Marshall's time a
woman who can go into woodworking lofric
department store in the old days she
could go in and buy a $200 dress could
not sit down and drink a 10-cent cup of
coffee in the stores cafeteria all that
and much more has changed because of
Thurgood Marshall and men like him what
do you think I mr. Clark actually I
think a lot of that was before my time
segregation certainly it was something
that affected my father and my mother
and my grandparents what I think about
these days is the visionary quality that
he had the impact that his opinions are
going to have on the court and the way
that his judicial philosophy will
influence today's judges and tomorrow's
judges long into the next century
kind of a what kind of person is he what
what are the things you would say about
it
I know you wrote a bunch of things yeah
despite the many landmark service
careers
chief counsel of lien double-a-c-p
later under our President Kennedy
Solicitor General on the federal bench
at the circuit level and later on the
Supreme Court Thurgood Marshall is a
kind of a guy who never took himself too
seriously he never lost his ability to
laugh at himself he never lost the
desire to give credit to other people
who were part of the massive and large
number of accomplishments and victories
that he won on behalf of not just black
Americans remember he won these for all
Americans
the Thurgood Marshall was always the guy
that could go to the bathroom and take
out deck of cards take out of a bourbon
she made no secret about and really be
one of the one of the boys he just never
became you know overly pretentious about
the butter's accomplish for us how long
did he serve on the Supreme Court
he served I believe 26 years from four
years on the Supreme Court 24 years on
the Supreme Court what wasn't doing
immediately before that before that he
was Solicitor General who is the lawyer
who represents the United States and
cases that come before the Supreme Court
and right before that before that he was
on the Second Circuit Court of Appeals
which covers a number of New England
states that was his first judicial
appointment and how did you two get
together to write this book and when did
you start on you mentioned earlier
Chrissa said where as a journalist I
probably started on the book about 25
years ago Hunter and I had been friends
for a long time
Hunter is a former journalist Time
magazine with our families have been
friends we're both fourth generation
Washingtonians
and we had thought about this book for
sometime and then there just came a time
when the time was right the process and
we decided we would sit down and write
the book what do you do for a living now
besides write books right now I'm
reading books and word you'll still live
in the what in Washington DC yes and
your case what are you doing I'm a
writer
for a living currently right now I'm
working on a biography of Justice
William Brennan and is this an
authorized biography of Thurgood
Marshall no well it isn't an
unauthorized biography when we
approached Justice Marshall about our
project he informed us that at that
particular point in time he had
completely abandoned the idea of
cooperating with anyone on a biography
about me that was the line that he that
he used and we think that he's reached a
point in his career and age and health
where he's perfectly content as well he
should be to let history judge his
accomplishments and achievements I don't
think he feels the need to put any
particular gloss on anything one way or
another how much did he cooperate with
you did you energy I have interviewed
him as a journalist through the years
Brian but not specifically for for this
book did you ask the Internet oh yes
inner city is a very polite response
that just summed up I think in a final
chapter of the book racism I have given
50 years to it you know let the people
decide in the acknowledgments you
acknowledge the family of Anita Jackson
Mitchell's right for allowing us to have
precious moments with her in the months
before her death
who is she or who was she Juanita
Jackson Mitchell's Baltimore returning
of course Thurgood Marshall was from
Baltimore she was the widow of Clarence
Mitchell the second who was a lobbyist
for the underbelly CP in the 50s and in
the 60s he was often referred to as a
hundred first senator with the Mitchell
family in Baltimore has long been active
in civil rights
it was dr. lily Jackson
why need a mixels mother who had worked
with Thurgood Marshall in the 30s
she was a president Lian double ACP and
she was really one of Thurgood
Marshall's mentors she got Thurgood
Marshall to organize pickets to
integrate the stores in Baltimore and of
course she is also the mother of former
Maryland senator Clarence Mitchell and
former Maryland representative Michael
Mitchell also an acknowledgement Edward
a Novak to third our literary agent for
inspiring us with the remark quote I
want this to be the book my daughters
Anna and Kate read one day to learn
about race relations in America Edie has
been very helpful to us it was our agent
of course and arranged the deal with
Carroll publishing company but what we
tried to do was what we set out to do
was write a commercial biography a
popular biography something that would
be easily accessible to the general
public we deal we deal with some
concepts and theories that are very
legalistic certainly the politics is
very complex you're talking about men
and women who consciously planned over
the course of years to bring about a
social revolution in America which they
in fact did yet we wanted to write about
these things in a very simple easygoing
readable and articulate way without
crossing the line into something that
was so much in the popular vein that it
didn't do justice to the complexity of
this man's thoughts and contributions
Edie reminded us where to find that line
he said write as if write for my
daughters let me let me be able to hand
this book to my daughters and say this
is the history of race relations this is
the history of
african-americans and their efforts
standard or the mainstream of American
society and that inspired us that
inspired us to write what we hope or
would like to think is is history true
history great history early in the book
you write about the automated elevator
at the Supreme Court and some tourists
that walked on with mr. Marshall Mr
Justice Marshall standing in the
elevator what happened right that's one
of the antidotes that I think is very
emblematic of Thurgood Marshall's life
that's a Supreme Court there is an
elevator reserved just for the justices
and on the particular occasion that you
refer to Thurgood Marshall had walked
through the Carter's of Supreme Court
without his robes regular business suit
as much as anyone else and a family of
white tourists we don't know where they
were from were spending a day at the
Supreme Court and mistakenly entered the
elevator with Thurid Marshall had
already stepped onto the elevator and
they assumed that he was the elevator
operator though it was an automatic
elevator well the families step to the
rear of the elevator car announced their
floor Thurgood Marshall looked at them
and he had a great ability to use black
dialect which he used to his great
advantage many times and he said yes oh
yes sir he pushed the floor when the
elevator arrived he you know stepped
back uh uh shirred the family out and
then very slowly as they walked down the
hall it dawned on them that this was
Thurgood Marshall and Thurgood Marshall
said he just sat there I stood there and
and just so he enjoyed it no end as I
slowly realized you know who he was but
this was the kind of man the Thurgood
Marshall was he said early on I intend
to wear a life like a loose garment he
had a driver from time to time and you
relate and they look how the driver of
Supreme Court justices had graded the
different justices on the way they were
he treated them sure most justices all
the justices they treated him excuse me
right all the justices in fact have
messengers who perform a number of
clerical and housekeeping functions also
serves almost as personal valets in some
instances and
justice marshall's chauffeur or
messenger whenever he drove him said
that Marshall was unlike the other
justices and that he was really engaged
him in conversation genuinely was
interested in what he thought not just
about the Redskins or the sports column
but how he felt about politics and how
he felt about social issues and in that
regard seem to have a little higher
respect for the for the little man the
Lula the UH the messenger the clerk the
guy who's the lower on the totem pole
some of the justices didn't do so well
not the grading of the driver or the
messengers did of other justices do you
remember who I remember for instance
that I think former justice Powell got
good marks for engaging the drivers and
justice Rehnquist the talks football and
justice bird you have his mother well I
think he's refer to Rehnquist said wrote
the Rehnquist would talk about football
but the weather and just the things that
you might have assuming the person
doesn't have the erudition to be
involved in while off the conversations
but the driver's name was was Lloyd
Roberts who has now about this minister
and said that Powell justice Powell was
also quite different he said pal talk to
him about religion during the time he
was a student at Howard University
School of divinity and then when he
graduated Powell gave him a one hundred
dollar graduation present but marshals
seem to be insisted all his life he
could there was a barber shop in a black
neighborhood in Washington DC called U
Street and a famous restaurant there
called a Florida Avenue grill where they
served so-called soul food and Thurgood
Marshall was a frequent visitor to the
Florida Avenue Grill he would hang
around the barber shop we talked with
his barber shortly before his death and
said that after the haircut Marshall
would sit around and we'd play poker
talk about civil rights drink bourbon
and eat pigs feet you did bring up some
of his personal traits and you mentioned
gambling and and I don't want to sound
pejorative but drinking and smoked
King and watching western movies workers
and poker would you like to talk through
that I think the I think the point is
just that he was a man who had a real
zest a zeal for life he once described
himself in an interview with Sidney Zion
of the New York Times as a hedonist with
no time for pleasure so he was a
sensualist and an a gregarious man but
very busy went to the racetrack went to
the racetrack right and Laura Morel he
was a freakin Tyrell bird and one of the
people he went to the racetrack with
Brian was van litter cab calloway could
have been his classmate at Lincoln
University and I talked to Calloway who
said yeah he was a followed Maryland
bred horses and was kind of just a $2.00
better he just enjoyed going there but I
imagine that he had these pursuits
because of the tremendous pressure under
which Thurgood Marshall operated that
these were just no applications maybe
that made life a little easier and made
his work a little easier for him Time
magazine when did you write for them and
what did you do I was a staff writer for
Time magazine from 1981 to 1986 based in
New York why'd you leave whiter leaf
time time has gone through a number of
changes as you know right now it's Time
Warner in fact time doesn't even exist
anymore but I think the company was in
the process of moving over into media
into a different area cable and
entertainment media and I decided it was
time to make a switch
were you born in Washington DC yes I was
born and raised in Washington and he
went to school where I attended Capitol
page school for high school and then
attended Harvard College and after that
Harvard Law School now the subject of a
black going to Harvard comes up in this
book who is the first block ever to go
to Harvard I think there's a picture in
here Oh
WEP Dubois was the first African
American to receive a graduate degree
from Harvard University he received his
PhD there Dubois was one of the founders
of the n-double a-c-p
a very prominent black writer and
thinker he wrote among other things
book called the souls of black folk
which is probably his most famous work
and why did you want to go to Harvard
Harvard provided in addition to its
prestige and the wonderful education I
got there
Harvard was looking for multicultural
diversity in its student body it
encouraged students to mix across racial
and cultural and economic lines it
presented an opportunity for a very
broad-based liberal arts education
certainly my years at Harvard College
were some of the most enjoyable years of
my life where'd you go school I went to
Morehouse College in Atlanta and that
also is an interesting story I had gone
to private prep schools like the Lincoln
Fieldston and was raised in a society
perhaps it was much different you know
from most blacks or other affluent
family and there came a time when it was
time to go to college that I wanted to
go south I had never you know I had read
about the South I had lived rather
protective environment and when I made a
decision I talked to my father about it
and that time Benjamin Mays who had been
my father's classmate at Bates College
and Lewiston Maine in 1926 was president
of Morehouse and I went south to
Morehouse and to was one of the most
rewarding periods of my life I became
involved in the civil rights movement I
was a close associate of dr. Martin
Luther King in fact I was arrested with
dr. King on five occasions at sit-ins in
Atlanta and throughout the south and it
was there of course after college that I
started my newspaper career on the
Atlanta Constitution under the tutelage
of Ralph McGill he referred earlier to a
lot of these things being things that
you've read in books and I get the
impression maybe there's a little
difference here an age and how you look
at this whole world if you don't mind
Hunter Clark how old are you I'm 37
years old and the Michael Davis I'm 53
that's a difference of about what are we
talking about 16 years Oh
sixteen years I want to show a picture
and ask the two of you to describe this
picture is from Marion Indiana and it's
fairly obvious what it is it's in the
public square and it's a lynching that
he didn't wanted to know what year this
was I don't remember offhand I believe
it was in the 1920s let me just ask the
two of you in 1826 when you see a
picture like that to describe how you
feel about it well I think quite frankly
I have seen pictures like that all of my
life as I said my father wasn't active
as I can remember going down and looking
through some books that my father had
from the Second World War and it was one
of the most disturbing pictures I've
ever seen in my life
a picture of dead Jews stacked like
cordwood and a basket on the side
holding gold that had been plucked from
their teeth and I saw that picture at
about the age of 8 years old I was aware
Second World War and the atrocities that
were happening in Europe and later when
I became aware that some of the things
were happening to black people in
America became disturbing and that
picture in the book is a story in itself
because before I submitted that
photograph to Noel black our editor in
New York I had to do some really deep
soul-searching but whether that picture
belonged in the book we had about five
lynching pictures and I called Hillel
hunter and I talked about is this the
kind of picture we need in the book and
Hillel said well we'll think about it
about two weeks later he said well it
tells the story and people need to see
you know exactly what happened how do
you look at I agree I think that's very
important because what we wanted to do
was establish the the history the social
context out of which thurgood marshall
emerged what it was exactly that that
african-americans confronted the kind of
virulent violence where
violent acts against blacks were common
and commonly went unpunished this was
the world in which he lived this was the
world that he changed there's a great
deal in the book about the early days
the n-double-a-cp the red summer of 1919
following World War one where there were
25 major race riots in the United States
including the deaths of hundreds of
blacks there was even an attempt here in
Washington by marauding White's to enter
the black residential section and burn
it to the ground
let me ask the two of you to describe
what's the worst thing you've seen
either put the word racism on it or the
kind of things you saw in your early
life what's the worst conditions that
you saw that got you involved in the
civil rights mode in the first place
well as a journalist I would I saw the
body of Emmett Till youngster who had
been lynched because he whistled at a
white woman
as Marty had been recovered from a river
after I've been in the river for about
three months well here oh I imagine this
must have been Melissa 1960-61 rate the
exact year of Emmett Till it was before
that it was around in the late 5th mid
50s
but the one thing I remember is his
mother insisted that the casket remain
open though the funeral director had
suggested ceremony there'd be a closed
casket funeral about he was mutilated
her well it had suffered you know from
the immersion um I had also um was on
the campus of Orangeburg South Carolina
in 1968 I was covering a demonstration
there and we were standing on a knoll
students have been demonstrating over
the opening of a bowling alley near the
campus in Orangeburg South Carolina once
led south
an acronym for their law enforcement
division South Carolina law enforcement
division opened fire on a group of
students and as almost at Kent State 151
children were shot five of them died
referred to as your Orangeburg massacre
and that was probably even worse than my
days in Vietnam as a worker responded
mr. Clark how about you what's the worst
you can remember it's very interesting
that Mike spoke of going wanting to go
to the south to college it was very much
in my father's mind that I should attend
school in the north because he wanted to
remove me from the culture that still
had the vestiges of segregation and and
racism which he regarded which he
associated with the South more than with
New England the other irony of that is
that when I went to Harvard I arrived
there in the middle of the busing crisis
it came in the 1970s and early 1970s on
into the late 70s and caused a lot of
violence between the black and white
communities there I the couple of
incidents stand out in my mind during my
time in Boston I remember working at a
very prestigious law firm one summer
doing a summer internship after my first
year of law school and at Palmer and
dodge on one Beacon Street which is the
very the heart of the financial district
and seeing a coming out for lunch and
seeing a black man beaten by a group of
rowdy whites in front of the State
Capitol
he was beaten with an American flag by a
group of people from South Boston who
were opposed to the busing order I
remember other things as well I remember
the retaliation I remember a white woman
in a Volkswagen whose car ran out of gas
in Roxbury the black section of Boston
and she went to get gas to fill her tank
and she was stopped on the way back to
her car and dragged in an alley and the
gas was poured on her and she was set up
she was a German exchange student what
was life like for Thurgood Marshall's
parents and what years do you have any
idea when this picture was taken yes
that picture was taken in nineteen it
was in the 40s a minute
somebody nothing maybe 1947 third
Marshall grew up in Baltimore Maryland
he was born one in 1908 and he grew up
in an area which the time was one of the
better areas of Baltimore off of Druid
Hill Avenue he his father had worked on
the railroad for a time which was not a
bad job in those days for a black man
many black fathers ran on the railroad
to put their sons through school his
mother an educated woman was a
schoolteacher in fact she was a
second-generation schoolteacher his
maternal and paternal grandparents owned
neighborhood grocery stores so Thurgood
Marshall grew up in a rather comfortable
home in Baltimore he had perhaps more
the amenities of life than most of his
black contemporaries had at the time his
father an uneducated man read very
widely
it was very interested in the courts and
as a hobby he would go down to the
Baltimore courthouse and just watch
cases and often took young Thurgood with
him his father was also one of the first
black men to serve on a grand jury in
Baltimore and when he noticed that they
always considered the race of a
prospective defendant before coming out
with an indictment he challenged that
and the white foreman of the grand jury
agreed with Thurgood Marshall's father
and from that time on that particular
grand jury never considered the race of
a suspect first before making that
determination to go back to the 1915 20s
25 all that era what was the difference
in a black person's life in this country
and a white person what could blacks not
do that White's could
the most important thing I think is just
that the color of your skin determined
everything about your life being black
determined where you could go to school
where you could live who you can marry
comfortably what jobs you could have
your color was the defining factor in
your life were there different public
restrooms and did you have to ride
different I mean these are obvious
questions but I had looking for you to
explain what it's like to somebody that
never lived in those era in that era
buses and Thurgood Marshall rentals an
interesting story during the early days
he was working in downtown Baltimore and
he had to go to the restroom well there
were no in the downtown Baltimore at
that time there were no public
facilities for black people and he said
he remembered that when he urged struck
him he hopped aboard the trolley car
hoping he would make it home in time and
his quote in the book was I made it as
far as my front door he said and I never
I never forgot that
of course Thurgood Marshall had also
worked at the Gibson Island Club on
Maryland's Eastern Shore as a waiter
where his father had worked and he had
been subject then you know to racial
remarks he but he was a proud man and I
would imagine that early on in his life
these incidents you know made the
foundation for his life but Baltimore I
was painfully proud we refer to it as
northern city was painfully proud of
being just south of the mason-dixon line
and the neighborhood he lived in at the
time was integrated and this was before
the white flight to the Maryland suburbs
of the of the 50s and you go back to
third of Marshalls old neighborhood
today neighborhood with the marble steps
that are scrubbed religiously on
Saturdays a carriage mount blocks on
Druid Hill Avenue in that neighborhood
and you'll see that many black churches
there were formerly Jewish synagogue
with the Stars of David still etched
near in their in their pediments where
did Thurgood Marshall go to
undergraduate school intended High
School in Baltimore no I mean I'm sorry
yeah undergraduate school graduate
Lincoln University in Pennsylvania and
what about Law School there's a whole
issue about sure one of the more
interesting and ironic things about his
life is that after he finished
undergraduate school he wanted to apply
to law school at the University of
Maryland in his home state he wanted to
practice in Baltimore his hometown but
was denied admission to the University
of Maryland because of his color that
caused him to go to Howard University in
Washington for Law School
and at Howard at the time Charles
Houston and other others in the
n-double-a-cp and at Howard along with
the help of many other prominent liberal
advocates were setting up a law school
that sought to combine the practice of
law with social engineering meaning
there F their desire was to turn out a
cadre a generation of younger lawyers
who would be committed to using the law
their legal skills to bring about social
change after he finished Howard law
school one of the first major cases that
Thurgood Marshall was involved in was
bringing suit against the University of
Maryland to force the integration of the
Law School at Maryland what happened to
suit
he was successful the case Murray V
Marylin went to the United to the
Supreme Court of the state of Maryland
and the court ordered the law school at
the University of Maryland integrated
this is a picture of Thurgood Marshall's
first wife
that's Vivian Buster Marshall who was a
graduate of the University of
Pennsylvania and he met her while he was
a student at Lincoln University he was
very close to her she was a guarding
influence in his life they were married
for 25 years for her death from cancer
but the impact of Vivian Marshall
Thurgood Marshall tells an interesting
story that
the school he went to was a religious
based institution and the students and
his undergraduate school were encouraged
to attend church on Sunday and he said
well we went to Cherry Hill Church in
Pennsylvania said not so much for
religious salvation that's where all the
pretty chicks were and that's where he
met Vivian Marshall and they married his
junior year so that firstly decided not
to marry until after he'd finished
school Marshalls mother liked her they
came back to Baltimore after he finished
his undergraduate work and Marshalls
mother and father made them very
comfortable in their Baltimore home was
from there he went to law school in
Vivian Marshall stayed by Thurgood side
and in 1954 when they were arguing the
Brown versus Maryland case she
discovered that she's poor Brown versus
Boyle that she had terminal cancer but
she would not tell Thurgood Marshall but
she was dying of cancer while he was in
the midst of arguing his greatest case
before the Supreme Court she kept this a
secret and didn't tell him about her
impending death until after that case
had what was was one Thurgood Marshall
said you know I thought the whole world
was coming to an end I just about
collapsed at this time the Marshalls
were living in Harlem New York 409
Edgecombe Avenue which was a fashionable
building for upcoming blacks at that
time and Thurgood Marshall withdrew from
all activity just recused himself from
everything and he said he just went
locked himself in their apartment spent
the whole time changing bedpans and
taking care of her until her death and
she died on what February the 11th her
birth her birth on her birthday 1954 yes
now let me ask you about another issue
too because you bring it up here's a
photograph of Thurgood Marshall Lyndon
Johnson being sworn in and standing by
his side as his wife off to the left of
the picture and his two sons you talk a
lot in this book about being
a light-skinned versus a dark-skinned
black and the fact that Thurgood
Marshall and now let me first ask you
was his first wife whiter bark his first
wife was black but light-skinned yes and
they had no children they had no
children and his second wife is Hawaiian
she is a Filipino of Philip Hawaiian of
Filipino descent and the two children
and the reason I bring this up is
because you mentioned in the book that
there was a controversy around the fact
that there's two sons married white
women well there was some controversy I
think on the part of other people there
was no controversy for Thurgood Marshall
no but I mean it was an issue why is it
an issue light skin versus dark skin and
is he considered light skin or dark skin
well he's a light skinned man with
straight hair
he's been very obviously there are lots
there's lots of different kinds of blood
running through his veins or the blood
of many nations and many people he's
been described variously as a man who
looks almost like a bedouin but he the
point I think the controversy between or
the divisions within the
african-american community those color
divisions or complexion divisions don't
really exist anymore
but earlier in the century it was
thought to be better to be more white
than than black it was an issue for the
n-double-a-cp
a very practical political problem for
them because a number of people who were
involved in the founding of the n-double
a-c-p and its first leaders were very
very light-skinned african-americans the
question was whether they could make
their movement and their organization
attractive to the masses of people and
whether the black masses would accept a
light-skinned leadership you know born
it was often said that the n-double-a-cp
actually was an organization of
privileged elite a light-skinned black
people and Thurgood Marshall himself
often joked that the initials
n-double-a-cp stood for the National
Association for the advantage of certain
people of course one of the will be
talked about his Baltimore days one of
his jobs was to carry the n-double-a-cp
his message to the so called blue-collar
black working class of Baltimore and to
get a broader base among people so it
didn't just seem to be the elite social
cocktail circuit kind of organization by
the way this is published by Burch Lyon
Press yeah who is that
birch lane press is a division of the
Carroll Publishing Group which is owned
and operated by Steven schragus and how
much does it sell for 2495 and did you
have to do certain things in this book
in order to make it you've mentioned
about being a commercial book earlier in
order to making a commercial success and
how will you how we decide or how will
they decide whether it's a commercial
success
well they'll decide whether it's a
commercial success or not by how many
copies it sells all right but I mean did
you have to did you have to do certain
things you didn't want to do become our
show no we had to one of the things I
really enjoyed about working with yellow
black our editors published so we had
complete literary freedom you know to
call the shots and to write the book as
we thought it should be written there
was no attempt on the part of the editor
or the publisher to make us put things
or to handle things a certain way
because they may have a commercial
infielder repect
impact we had complete academic freedom
the preparation of this book you have
two chapters in here chapter 11 I'm
sorry chapter 12 and 13 Brown versus the
Board of Education part 1 and part 2 how
come it needed two parts Brown was a
very long litigation well first of all
Brown is probably Thurgood Marshall's
most important achievement as a lawyer
certainly as a case it stands as perhaps
the most significant legal opinion of
the 20th century in terms of its social
impact who is brown well actually the
case is a consolidation of five cases
that were brought before the Supreme
Court to challenge segregation in the
with schools the most one of those cases
came from Kansas Brown versus Topeka
Board of Education but the case that
Marshall handle personally came out of
South Carolina Clarendon County South
Carolina involving Harry Briggs Harry
and Eliza Briggs and their young
daughter who sought to force either the
integration or the equalization of the
South Carolina Public Schools and Part
one and Part two again the years that
the Brown versus the Board of Education
was argued what years what started in 53
but it came uh actually nineteen fifty
was what if you wait but the decision
came in fifty four and I think we have
two chapters Brian because we wanted to
lay this is an important case we want
the lay out the history of this case but
of course it didn't end with that
decision there was a reaaargh ument in
brown which was as important thing you
know I think as the first argument and
there just seemed to be logical breaking
points wouldn't you say hunter well yeah
to put it in context the n-double-a-cp
began a litigation strategy during the
1920s designed to challenge the
separate-but-equal doctrine the
separate-but-equal doctrine had been
established by the supreme court in 1896
in the case of Plessy versus Ferguson
this is what gave the courts blessing
the courts imprimatur to the system of
separating people by race segregation in
public accommodations public education
elsewhere it's the thing that's set up
the two separate societies what the
n-double-a-cp initial goal was was to
show that African Americans were being
accorded separate treatment but
treatment that was not in fact equal and
the purpose of the strategy was to force
equality of treatment the idea being
that most states would probably decide
that it was easier just to integrate
their schools or their public
accommodations than to set up a wholly
separate but equal school system for
blacks
or system of public accommodations like
it's hard and 11 amount of time we have
to get through all this but let me just
read a quote that got my attention when
I read it and he explained it one of the
attorneys for South Carolina looked at
marshals seated across the council table
and a voice loud enough for everyone in
the courtroom to hear he told him if you
show your black ass in Claridon County
again he'll be dead
what's the circumstances around that
quote hundred was yes this was just
after this was the Briggs case in which
Marshall challenged on behalf of black
school children in South Carolina
challenged the inequalities in the South
Carolina school system the case went up
to the Supreme Court of the United
States but was remanded to the South
Carolina courts what his remand mean
sent back for further consideration
basically the state of South Carolina
argued well the state of South Carolina
conceded that it's black school system
was not as good as its white school
system that the black schools had
suffered from over a hundred years of
neglect but it promised the courts that
if the courts did not order
desegregation the state would make up
for the neglect of the past by
initiating a crash program of building
and recruiting better teachers and
bringing the black schools up to a equal
status with the whites with the white
schools the US Supreme Court at first
refused to take the case to challenge
desegregate to challenge segregation
itself and instead remanded it meaning
sent it back to the South Carolina
courts to determine how fast South
Carolina was making progress in bringing
its black schools up to par the judge in
the South Carolina case the South
Carolina Supreme Court decided the
progress was in fact being made that the
progress was being made fast enough to
satisfy the Constitution and therefore a
case dismissed
and at that point the attorney for the
state of South Carolina turned to
Thurgood Marshall and said what you just
quoted how'd you find that out
find that how do you know that well we I
don't remember exactly the source for
that but there were a tremendous number
of sources that we used to research the
background of this particular case I
don't recall off the top of my head
where that particular quote came from
probably a newspaper article of the time
or I don't remember there's there's a
lot more to this Brown versus the Board
of Education and a lot more than I know
I remembered about the two different
sets of supreme court appearances a
chief justice that died in the middle of
it all but before you tell that story
how had Thurgood Marshall put himself in
a position to be the person leading the
charge on this thurgood marshall went to
work for his mentor Charles Hamilton
Houston who had gone to New York to head
up the legal operation for the
underbelly CP Bryant he went there as
deputy about 1950 when Charles Hamilton
Houston became ill he returned to
Washington where he spent the final year
or so of his life and Thurgood Marshall
then became the chief legal counsel to
the young double ACP but there came a
time a few years later where the
strategy was to divorce the
n-double-a-cp s
legal operation from the so called civil
rights operation and they formed a legal
corporation called a little defense and
educational fund later partly referred
to as the Inc fund and then just the fun
this became the legal arm of the
n-double a-c-p there were certain tax
advantages to having the little defense
funds separated from the n-double-a-cp
little Defense Fund operating you know
as the legal arm did not have to pay
certain taxes and they had more freedom
to operate than if it had remained a
part of the in doubly sleepy and third
grade became chief counsel and as chief
counsel he normally fell into the
position of being in charge of
all and double-a-c-p litigation because
it was the Inc fund that was going into
the courts of Alabama and in Mississippi
and not just on schools like going in
the school cases came much later they
were involved in efforts to remove the
poll tax voting rights and a lot of
other things before they worked their
way up to what we refer to as the wedge
the brown case which they say down with
the brown case at Thurgood Marshall
dismantled the system of American
apartheid but Thurgood Marshall was the
lawyer in fact it was in the fifties a
black-and-white media started referring
to him as mr. civil rights and as the
chief lawyer for the n-double a-c-p when
the headlines were written on the
newscast went out it wasn't the name of
n-double-a-cp president Roy Wilkins it
was foremost in the minds of Americans
and they thought about the n-double
a-c-p was Thurgood Marshall and you know
one thing if you look at the court today
and we spent a lot of time looking at
the court the arguments before the court
are an hour long divided thirty minutes
on one side thirty minutes on the other
page 165 this is the first of Brown
versus the Board of Education
it went on for three days the arguments
the questions the answers and rebuttals
when it was over there was nothing to do
but wait the ultimate judgment of the
court three days well you have to
remember there were five cases that were
consolidated into brown and they all
were argued together the first time
around they were all argued together how
many of those cases were argued you said
the only the South Carolina case was
argued by Thurgood Marshall no Thurgood
market actually Thurgood Marshall argued
the South Carolina case and I believe
one other case actually during the oral
arguments before the court but he had
overall charge of the litigation and
divided up the cases delegating
authority to certain members of his
staff well that he was in charge of them
you say that five appeared initially to
be in favor of ending segregation Hugo
black William Douglas Burton I don't
know his first name Felix Frankfurter
and Sherman Minton the Lib
former senator from Indiana yes and then
there were four on the other side
needing you need five four you need five
votes Chief Justice Benson Robert
Jackson who William Rehnquist clerked
for Stanley Reed and Tom Clark so what
happened at that that first go-around in
1953 Chief Justice Benson was there what
happened right the court decided to ask
for a second round of arguments in the
cases in the meantime the parties were
supposed to present their answers to
five specific questions posed by the
court those questions in essence had to
do with the courts power to overturn the
system of segregation and with the
legislative history of the Fourteenth
Amendments Equal Protection Clause the
idea we have been led to believe by our
research is that the court the people
who favored desegregation wanted to come
closer to arriving at if a unanimous
decision if possible and that at the
time of the first round of oral
arguments in Brown unanimity was not
attainable since here the justices
issued a per curiam order on June 8 1953
per curiam aims for clear him as a
simple order unaccompanied by any
explanation of the logic or rationale
because the legal issues are considered
settled already to reaaargh you though
yes June 8 1953 and and the reaaargh
ument was scheduled for Monday October
the 12 1953 and in the interim chief
justice Vincent died right what did that
create well her what you said certainly
change the vote of the court that he was
not replaced right away right well the
most important thing that it did was it
brought justice Earl the Chief Justice
Earl Warren into the picture Earl Warren
was appointed to replace Vincent and
Warren was a self self-professed
was a self-professed believer in one law
for all men he had a very interesting
background it served as governor of
California and at that time had been a
member of a white supremacist
organization the native sons of the
Golden West he also had urged President
Roosevelt to incarcerate Japanese
American citizens during World War two
which in fact was the policy that was
implemented 110,000 Japanese were
interned
110,000 Japanese American citizens were
interned in California well actually all
over the west coast at Ora Warren's
prompting so what what did Thurgood
Marshall feel about Earl Warren coming
in as chief justice
he was very he was apprehensive you had
to question you know the question of
man's record which was quite public
where the man stood ironically you know
history I guess was on the side of
Thurgood Marshall because we know now
that Earl Warren just like well justice
Hugo black it was a former member of the
Klan certainly changed during the years
and when we look at history we might say
that black and learn happy or became
certainly in our great supporters of
equal rights for minorities how did you
two divide out this book my way how did
we divide this back haphazardly by
chance I imagine that we have we of
course hunter is the is a lawyer so as
you might expect you know he handled you
know most of the details dealing with
the intricacies of the law I had the
experience of civil rights background
and so I had word most of the materials
you know dealing with Thurgood
Marshall's life with his relationships
with people like Malcolm X with Martin
Luther King the chapter we write about
civil disobedience versus the old God
we're in the sixties the young students
and they're impatient
attitude towards real gradualism was
challenging challenge people like Roy
Wilkins and and Martin Luther King and
then of course you know after we kind of
you know carved out we got together and
just you know and polished it and meld
it and notice that's the good word
before we come to the end of the Brown
versus Board of Education which I want
to get to you keep quoting him but
Thurgood Marshall was saying here I see
no reason to say he Malcolm X is a great
person a great Negro and I asked a
simple question what did he ever do
Namie one concrete three thing he ever
did where'd you get that was his quote I
got that talking to several people in
New York who had been close to him the
vet quote by the way is a quote that he
made as early as his return he was asked
on Davis retirement and this was before
the Malcolm X Renaissance so to speak
early in his days in Harlem Thurgood
Marshall was approached one night on the
street corner by a group of black
Muslims this was before Malcolm X had
separated himself ere logically you know
from Elijah Muhammad and then New York
Police Chief Joseph P Kennedy was
concerned for Marshalls safety because
he had gotten an argument with black
Muslims who didn't who would call
Thurgood and Uncle Tom
a white man's [ __ ] who had felt that
integration was not the solution and the
police chief showed up at Marshalls
apartment one night with a 38 caliber
pistol and offered to him for protection
and he refused it then Marshall told
later of another night when he met
Malcolm X on me I think it was the
corner of 125th Street Amsterdam Avenue
one night he says yeah we spent the
whole night calling each other a bunch
of sob s so I don't think that Thurgood
Marshall has really ever embraced the
separatist strategy that Malcolm X was
preaching at the time we got to end
we're at most a time we've got to end it
by giving the final chapter on the board
versus the Brown versus the Board of
Education what happened at the end and
54 eventually the Supreme Court
unanimously
I did with the n-double-a-cp and ordered
and said that segregation in public had
no place in public education under the
Constitution what was the vote nine to
nothing
how did chief Nana mrs. Justice Warren
do that basically Thurgood Marshall had
argued in his brief that the only reason
segregation had ever been imposed was
because of a belief in the inferiority
of African Americans when Earl Warren
called together the justices to consider
Brown he said very simply to them I
agree with Thurgood Marshall that
segregation was imposed out of the
belief that blacks are inferior if
anyone here believes that they should be
willing to say it openly to write it
straightforwardly and if no one is
willing to do that then I think we have
unanimous decision Clarence Thomas
replaced Thurgood Marshall what did he
think of that third Marshall was asked
what day of his retirement if his seat
on the Supreme Court had become a
so-called black seat
Thurgood Marshall refused to address
that he said I see you know a competent
person I say you know no reason to
appoint a person as a Supreme Court just
because he is a black person
interestingly enough on the day of his
retirement the president had already
formed his shortlist for that season of
course you know one name that list was
was Clarence Thomas
but as hunter has said you know
continually it is very very difficult to
judge what how a Supreme Court justice
well we turn out you know we looked at
you Oh blacks they're all Warren's of
our era and it's of course with the new
democratic administration coming in the
possibilities of mr. Clinton could have
several appointments in the next few
years Clarence Thomas may not play you
know the role that we envisioned it
limit is your life better because of
Thurgood Marshall Oh absolutely
positively what do you think what's the
difference and we only have a few
seconds legally at least if not in
practice America is now truly a multi
multiracial democracy this is what the
book looks like we didn't really get
much below the surface Michael Davis 100
Clarke the co-authors of Thurgood
Marshall thank you very much thank you